bom né meu nome é lúcio
eu gostaria de agradecer primeiro um
convite essa oportunidade está falando
para vocês aqui eu vou falar um
pouquinho de algo que está na moda né é
na verdade nosso mundo está sendo
habitado por drones então é falar um
pouquinho que são esses drones
o que esses drones de fato podem ser
feitos ou falar podem fazer pra gente
como eles podem ser feitos enfim é uma
pincelada é claro que eu falo demais 18
minutos seria impossível falar tudo mas
vamos tentar passar uma ideia
interessante para vocês
o drone pela própria palavra tradução do
inglês zangam então vem propriamente do
barulho que o dispositivo faz por isso
conhecido e foi difundido tem sido
difundido mas na verdade ele é o que é
um veículo aéreo não tripulado um
veículo aéreo é não tripulado no brasil
inicialmente foi chamado denominado de
vant e agora muito conhecido por toni e
na verdade pela legislação e pela anac
tudo mais está se tentando passar para a
denominação de r pa sistemas remotamente
pilotados justamente para algumas
limitações que a tecnologia impõe é
basicamente que quer um drone drone pra
gente não é só aquele com azia rotativa
não que a gente viu ali do lado no de
cima da da figura mas também pode ser
pra gente um de asa fixa no leite
pãozinho como se fosse aquele onde era
modelo
a característica desses dispositivos são
eles o mais importante é uma aeronave
todos eles têm capacidade de vôo é
sobrevoar e vai fazer o quê vai olhar
por cima o nosso mundo e tentar nos
trazer uma outra visão pra diversas
aplicações seja a fixa seja asa rotativa
no mesmo tem as suas especificidades
o mais importante pra gente o que ele
carrega é o sensor é o que a gente pode
ou como que a gente enxergar o mundo aí
néné durante a operação é aqui só tem
uma idéia e um esboço muito rápido da
eletrônica que vai do drone é para
chamar atenção seguinte
dependendo da aplicação você pode
simplesmente tem um quase brinquedo que
é muito simples a gente vai mostrar e
tem um grande aplicação também é
simplesmente você subir fazer o seu self
e tudo mais mas também o miolo a parte
mais importante do drone na hora de eu
comprar um drone é o seu piloto
automático que tipo de dispositivo e que
tem e que tipo de dispositivo é o que
lhe permite você fazer
tá então tem piloto que realmente quase
que pilota totalmente autônoma pra você
o piloto totalmente autónomo e tem
piloto que vai só ajudar a estabilizar a
aeronave para você fazer você fazer o
vôo está então é isso é só pra chamar a
atenção tem uma parafernalha já chama a
atenção que tem um monte de itens
eletrônicos e isso pode dar problema
então só para lembrar que eu diria que a
maior experiência minha é antes de da
construção do drone do uso de drones nas
quedas dos drones está então a gente vai
falar já se eu bato na tecla que é
extremamente importante
os drogas eles vem lá de trás na verdade
não é de agora
em 1907 nós vemos aí a criação
praticamente do giroscópio é e depois em
1917 dez anos depois é começou a ser
usado como torpedos aéreos os sistemas
dispositivos de controle é esse
dispositivo que é essencial pra
navegação do drone
veja bem que não 1917 pra cá olha o
tanto que passou e só agora que a gente
graças ao chinesas grande parte eles
estão aí no dia a dia pra gente bastante
acessível
eu não vou passar todo o histórico dos
drones no brasil tem uma história e na
verdade começou ser claro sempre na área
militar
internacionalmente como nacionalmente a
grande força sempre há uma militar e
depois o uso civil
nós temos algumas iniciativas antigas no
brasil de construção de plataformas
totalmente autônoma para geração isso da
tam e da década de 80 é uma pena é
belíssimas exemplos só que estavam fora
do tempo eles não estavam
tecnologias que foram construídos por
uma equipe brilhante de engenheiros por
exemplo projeto helix do rio grande do
sul
outros projetos da própria aeronáutica
enfim mas eles não estavam prontos
talvez nos tinha o dispositivo chineses
para poder chegar ao público final
é a gente vê em hoje o mas a gente
procura na internet rapidamente
não é aquele modelinho simplesmente de
asa rotativa é o mais famoso phantom
zinho por exemplo que a gente consegue
achar a gente consegue achar uma gama
muito grande e para aplicações distintas
desde área militar ainda área civil por
exemplo nós na agricultura e diversas
áreas têm vários modelos vários sistemas
então é até difícil escolher e vários
preços por exemplo é aquele do canto
está sendo usado na agricultura superior
ele não é nada vale muito é muito
diferente de um drone de asa rotativa
que a gente está acostumado a ver com os
280 mil reais
a idéia do preço usa uma câmera comum tá
e na verdade mas é não é é bastante
robusto é um modelo alemão é mas tem
muita gente comprando só passa bem ea
gente vai falar e têm modelos por
exemplo como este aqui do lado direito
lado esquerdo e direito
é em cima ora linha aqui é um modelo
bastante usado tem mais hoje de 200
unidades vendidas no brasil para
agricultores e outras áreas
é um modelo muito simples tá você joga
com a mão e ele vai e faz sua missão e
volta permitindo carregar alguns tipos
de sensores bastante interessantes e se
aquietam modelos híbridos que aquele
modelo onde você não pode voar em uma
pista de decolagem ou é mais difícil o
deslocamento então você sobe com as asas
rotativas e depois desloca com a asa
fixa então são modelos híbridos que
estão vindo para o mercado
e aí tem vários modelos até a asa que
imitam insetos que batem as asas e saem
em borboletas isso aí também já está
disponível já a gente enxerga esse é um
modelo híbrido da nasa bastante é
defendido deve ser aplicado na área
agrícola
aí também
a gente olhar a tendência é sair de vant
de alguns repórteres que aquela comissão
como comunidade européia
na verdade a gente percebe que tem
várias aplicações agricultura área de
energia setores de observação de uma
forma de entretenimento também deve sair
broadcast na comunicação e o governo
como sendo uma tendência muito pode
fazer
o drone está vindo o drone veio e vai
ficar tatá na verdade nós ainda temos
alguns problemas ligados ao uso gente
vai falar sobre eles mas o drone tá aí
como tendência bastante marcante no
nosso dia a dia e com ele por exemplo
até a nossa ministra da agricultura por
exemplo fazendo já como capa no facebook
dela da tecnologia no campo coloca lá o
quê
um drone né responde então você vê cada
hora é a divulgação da tecnologia em
diversas áreas
nós é claro tem uma experiência muito
forte na agricultura a que são modelos
nosso laboratório onde tem um campo
experimental uma unidade onde desenvolve
adaptar sistemas pra poder
esse é um helicóptero por exemplo que a
gente usa pra a experimentação em campo
porque usa helicóptero na verdade eu não
uso só é contra o uso afixada rotativa e
vários modelos e se daqui porque leva
bastante sensor bastante carga possa
levar 35 quilos aí e de sensores e poder
explorar bastante e posso ter diferentes
modelos por exemplo pequenos é no
sistema desde que custa 5 mil reais para
se montar um agricultor pode montar e
nós exemplo desse aqui nós monitoramos
uma fazenda de 5 mil hectares com
facilidade
então na verdade aqui uma imagem também
escura mas é uma reconstrução é pra
querer passar o seguinte nosso mundo
está sendo olhado diferentes ângulos
agora com drones e uma vez que tal lhe
sendo olhado mapeado diferentes ângulos
ele começa até perfeitamento elas para
que eu consiga montar essas imagens
a grande diferença do drone de um avião
convencional é porque ele vai ter um
monte de imagens pra mim e vou ter que
juntar essas imagens juntar esses
mosaicos para enxergar o mundo de forma
diferente mas chegar
mundo eu tenho assessor ou a câmera
então mais comum todo mundo acostumado a
usar aquela câmera que a gente tá
tirando foto enxerga no visível né
mas para várias aplicações engenharias e
outras muitas vezes enxergarem outras
espectros shopping infravermelho que é o
mais comum e pessoal
então tem que ver diferentes tipos de
sensores e isso vai diferenciar o tipo
de drone que eu vou usar o tipo led o
tempo de operação
na verdade muitas vezes tem que começar
a minha aplicação o que eu quero fazer
com drone qual o sensor me atende aquilo
depois que o define o sensor eu vou
definir o drone não é comprar o drone e
depois de tentar fazer a coisa tá que é
o que muita gente faz
então aqui nós temos sensores multi
espectrais por exemplo tem ideia é essa
câmera aqui ela uma câmera tipo
espectral para várias aplicações é uma
câmera que é como subir 300 câmeras
juntas ela tem 300 bandas espectrais
então você consegue enxergar muita coisa
agora quando falo você chegar muita
coisa é muita banda são 300 imagens e
cada imagem posição que o drone tateando
uma imagem que vem à cabeça grande
quantidade de dados grande computador
para processar grandes software para
processar enfim
de repente grande no ponto de vista de
tempo de processamento olhar cultura eu
posso simplesmente tirar uma foto no
visível como eu posso processar essa
foto enxergar a planta por exemplo ver
no qual a planta que também desenvolvida
para isso é preciso uma câmera um
pouquinho melhor
então o drone a ferramenta que vai
permitir um olhar por cima mas a câmera
que vai me permitir realmente enxergar
diferenças também uma câmera no visível
uma câmera com aquelas várias bandas
enxerga na mesma área ali eu posso
enxergar onde está havendo deficiência
aonde está tendo alterações a mesma
coisa pode ser feita em linha de
transmissão saber onde tem por exemplo
uma falha em uma linha de transmissão eu
posso saber na parte de engenharia
materiais etc
então na verdade o sensor é fundamental
e quando a gente fala de sensor o
próprio drone ao pra operar o drone
muito bem eu tenho que ter um planejador
demissão eu tenho que trabalhar com
drone
eu posso simplesmente usar um drone aí
eu subo e desço 10 motoristas que gostam
né
sob controle e tira as imagens e vai
vender as imagens é só vender as imagens
não me serve
eu tenho de planejar o meu vôo esse vôo
de alguma forma ser supervisionado por
exemplo montar essa imagem de uma área
experimental nossa tem aqui 300 imagens
foram tiradas
eu tenho que na verdade juntar essas
várias imagens tão cada posição do
petróleo estava ele tirou uma foto eu
tenho que montar um mosaico
então esse é uma toda vez que eu penso
não comprar um drone eu tenho que pensar
em qual software vai juntar essas
imagens e qual software vai me ajudar
a aeon já tem bastante solução é enfim
em diversas áreas
é hoje o drone aparece aí como tendência
por isso aqui é um anúncio de uma
empresa não todos em qual empresa está
fazendo inspeção aérea com drone ou
japão e até nomenclatura é drone r passa
aí
e aqui uma área de engenharia para
simplesmente planejar um vôo para
provavelmente avaliar o acompanhamento
de uma obra bom muito legal tá na mídia
só está proibido
então hoje tem um monte de gente
vendendo prendendo casamento tem gente
que aliás eu não ficar embaixo mas a
noiva adora ser vista pelas várias
ângulos né
mas aquilo ali tem um risco ainda antes
não está legalizado a pessoa que faz
isso está incorrendo em alguns erros mas
tem a tecnologia está vindo e ela vai
virar habitar no nosso dia a dia e por
isso que essa técnica a legislação tem
que se ajustar a gente vai falar nela
aqui praticamente reserva está em moda
agora é o tal do siga me pessoal adorou
fazer self né então antes de o pau de
self agora tem o drone self de self
então você conheça aqui do dispositivo
no braço
joga o braço assim o dispositivo vai na
programação que você fez e ele olha pra
você tira da internet acompanhando
então isso é é o boom do momento aqui
alguns à prova de água este dispositivo
aqui por exemplo se adquire por mil
dólares
é você pode jogar na água e depois olha
que no pulso do da pessoa tem um
dispositivo que ele vai fazer para que
eu aciono ele sobe e vai seguir o carro
o rapaz que está fazendo a canoagem e
tudo mais então na área de esportes na
área de entretenimento enfim tem uma
gama muito grande de aplicações
esse é um modelo diferente já usa uma
câmera chamada gol pró ficou muito
popular na área de esportes é muito rico
e simplício doni também você pode falar
num beira de um abismo de um penhasco
jogar ele e tem uma visão panorâmica com
você lá na ponta do abismo pois é muito
fácil um modelo está disponível e está
vindo pra ficar com dispositivos de
segurança
pousa na sua mão muito simples fácil de
vocês acharem na internet é tão são
modelos chamados inteligentes cada vez
mais está mais inteligente mas lembrar
que de repente essa inteligência
essa quantidade de drones aí pode trazer
algumas dificuldades né
será que a amazon quando colocou essa
mita mídia que está entregando
mercadorias assim uma nuvem de drones
invadindo a cidade entregando a ação
mercadorias a encomenda
imagina isso entra num prédio onde o
cara mora lá no meio do tratamento do do
meio como o drone foi na janela de lhe
entregar na porta e os fios na rua como
ele vai passar por tudo isso se tiver
mais um drone detecta o outro drone ele
desvia se ele pegar um cara com
helicóptero vai derrubar o helicóptero
vai fazer também age na 6a exagero ou
não na verdade é que nós temos hoje no
dia a dia tem muita gente e se
aventurando fazendo a aaa a aa o uso dos
drones mas muitas vezes de forma
inconsequente sem pensar exatamente no
que é utopia ou não falar que eu era
encomendar uma pizza e vou receber a
minha pizza com o drone lá em casa né
na verdade eu acho que assim nós temos
algumas restrições nós estamos
dando a honra a talvez a é esse momento
mas ainda deixa a desejar já tem na
mídia gente tocando o gado com um drone
primeiro que o droga e nem carrega esse
chapéu tá então nessa versão e sidrônio
que está aí não suporta nem cinco
minutos com esse chapéu e então é claro
a mídia é a gente querendo aparecer ea
gente querendo difundir algo que ainda
não é real mas existem coisas reais
o facebook por exemplo está
desenvolvendo inclusive selecionando o
brasil como nas áreas de testes para
poder usar o drone ou desse tipo que têm
sistema de carregamento de bateria solar
que deve voar dias e pode levar a
internet em pontos onde não tem internet
é isso aqui foi a de são carlos só pra
falar são carlos humano na padaria pão
do gol
não quero fazer propaganda mas amigos
nossos conhecidos subiram com drone
filmar e saiu até na mídia um jornal de
são paulo são paulo tudo mais mas é
mentira ele não voa e não leva isso daí
não ainda não dá pra fazer isso isso aí
vou ap 15 minutos só então não dá para
entrar na casa mas a boeing por exemplo
acabou de divulgar uma patente que ele
desenvolveu um um dispositivo que vai
permitir algumas torres que vão fornecer
energia e uma conexão em tempo real
então nós não por ter te drones voando e
sendo carregados ao longo do tempo
portanto isso daí não é o futuro muito
distante já é real já é patente
já saí daqui a pouquinho pra gente temos
legislação só pra fechar questão meu
último minutos
basicamente o seguinte está proibido de
dona autônomo na cidade está proibido
esquece quem quer uma cidade que estava
doendo tá voando atuando de forma
irregular
se cair na cabeça de alguém vai ser
processado
a anac tem uma regulamentação e está
gerando agora uma nova documentação que
vai sair para consulta pública nos
próximos nas próximas semanas para poder
regularizar esse uso só pode ser usado
por enquanto experimental mente em áreas
não habitadas
tá é é a ficar à disposição pra depois
quem quiser mais detalhes
espero ter dado uma pincelada dinha
sobre o tema o tema é muito rico mas
fica pra oportunidade obrigado